all of us students here at Hillsdale
studied Pericles funeral oration the
citta sees records his words to the
Athenians the bravest are surely those
who have the clearest vision of what is
before them glory and danger alike and
yet notwithstanding go out to meet it a
year ago American conservatives were in
retreat and disarray the media chanted
to Republicans you must become rahman
irr 'it's or go extinct the specter of
our new president's post Christian post
American world loomed in progressive
nominated Congress courts and White
House it seemed like there was no line
left for us to hold a few leaders saw
the personal and political dangers of
standing fast by principle yet forged on
with vision as president of the
Hillsdale College Republicans it is my
honor to introduce you to one of those
leaders Congressman Mike Pence of
Indiana his uncompromising vision was
recognized by the American Conservative
Union who honored him in 2006 with the
courage under fire award he was named
Man of the Year in 2005 by human events
standing among previous recipients of
these honors such as Justice Clarence
Thomas Charlton Heston and Ronald Reagan
he demonstrated his conviction by
standing against his own party opposing
the prescription drug benefits expansion
of health care entitlements he voted
against No Child Left Behind because he
believed it undermined local control of
Education through its federal mandates
something we at Hillsdale ought to know
something about he led the largest
caucus in Congress the House Republican
Study Committee which under his
chairmanship grew to 110 members and has
consistently given birth to intelligent
conservative alternatives to the
Bohemian state last week on September
12th
he told thousands of Americans standing
before the United States Capitol there
is nothing that ails this government
that could not be solved by paying more
careful attention to the principles
enshrined in the Constitution of the
United States like the beacon of truth
we shine here at Hillsdale and now in
Washington at the Kirby Center
congressman pence continues in the
practices of the Constitution and in the
principles of the Declaration of
Independence that our education has
instilled in us
on behalf of the Hillsdale College
Republicans and Hillsdale College we are
honored to present please welcome the
Honorable Congressman Mike Pence
president and mrs. Arendt mr. John
Savini dr. David Bob and Eliot college
Republicans and each and every one of
the faculty gathered here today and all
the students here at Hillsdale College
who've taken time good evening as I'm
sure you know honor is what allows us to
do what is right despite the cost even
greater honor is required to do what is
right in the face of superior power and
the greatest honor is to stand strong
even when it means standing alone the
long fight of Hillsdale College standing
alone then and now for the proposition
that all men are created equal then with
Frederick Douglass now with Clarence
Thomas then in now in the conviction
that Americans are not horses we were
not born to have saddles on our backs by
anyone at any time for any reason this
long fight you at Hillsdale have fought
for love of ideas that did not come in
dreams or as Regan said did not spring
full bloom from your brow but came from
the heart of a great nation ideas that
rose in a time of unprecedented stress
and genius and since the founding have
kept this country whole prosperous safe
just and free it is therefore a profound
honor for me to stand before you in this
place so closely associated with the
founding of the Republican Party
in opposition to the unforgivable sin of
slavery this place where statesmanship
has taught as an art and where right
conduct is seen as its own reward I
thank you and may God bless you and God
bless Hillsdale College
I rise to pay a debt of honor and a debt
to history my subject today is the
presidency and my hope is that you will
see that institution in a new light and
that you never despair of the Republic
the presidency is the most visible
thread that runs through the tapestry of
the American government more often than
not for good or for ill it sets the tone
for the other branches and spurs the
expectations of the people its powers
are vast and consequential its
requirements from the outset and by
definition impossible for mortals to
fulfill without humility an insistent
attention to its purpose as set forth in
the Constitution of the United States
isn't it amazing
given the great and momentous nature of
the office that those who seek it seldom
pause to consider what they are seeking
rather unconstrained by principle or
reflection there seems to be a mad rush
towards something that once its powers
are seized the new President can wield
it as an instrument with which to
transform the nation and the people
according to his highest aspirations but
other than in the crisis of a house
divided the presidency is neither fit
nor intended to be such an instrument
when it is made that the country
sustains a wound and cries out justly
and indignantly and what the nation says
and the theme of this address what it
says informed by its long history
impelled by the laws of nature and
nature's God what it says quite
naturally and rightly if not always
gracefully is the
we as a people are not to be ruled and
not to be commanded it says that the
president should never forget this that
he has not risen above us but is merely
one of us chosen by ballot dismissed
after his term tasked not to transform
and work his will upon us but to bear
the weight of decision and to carry out
faithfully to design laid in the
Constitution and impassioned by the
Declaration of Independence the
presidency must adhere to its definition
as expressed in the Constitution and to
conduct itself the conduct that is
defined over time and tradition while
the powers of the office have enlarged
with those of the legislature and the
judiciary the framework of the
government was actually intended to
restrict abuses common to classical
empires and the regal states of the 18th
century without proper adherence to the
role contemplated in the Constitution
for the presidency the checks and
balances of the constitutional plan
become weakened this has been most
obvious in recent years when the three
branches of government have been subject
to the tutelage of a single party under
either party presidents have often
forgotten that they are intended to
restrain Congress at times and that the
Congress is independent of their desires
and thus fused in some unity the
political class has raged forward an
expansion of powers and prerogatives
mistakenly assuming that to exercise
power is by default to do good even the
simplest among us knows that this is not
so power is an instrument of fatal
consequence it is confined no more
readily than Quicksilver it escapes good
intentions as easily as air flows
through
therefore those who are entrusted with
it must educate themselves in
self-restraint a republic if you can
keep it
it's about limitation and for good
reason because we are mortal and our
actions are imperfect the tragedy of
presidential decision is that even with
the best choice some perhaps many will
be left behind and some perhaps many
could die because of this truth the true
statesman lives continuously with what
Churchill called stress of soul he may
give to Paul but only because he Rob's
Peter and that is why you must always be
wary of a president who seems to float
on his own greatness for all greatness
is tempered by mortality every soul is
equal distinctions among men cannot be
owned they are on loan from God who
takes them back and evens the accounts
in the end it's a tragedy indeed that
new generations taking office attribute
failures in governance to insufficient
power and seek more of it in the
judiciary this has seldom been better
expressed than by Justice Thurgood
Marshall's dictum that you do what you
think is right and let the law catch up
in the Congress it presents itself in
massive legislation acts and codes
thousands of pages long and so
monstrously overcomplicated that no
human being can read through them in a
lifetime much less understand them much
less apply them justly to a people that
increasingly feel that they they
no longer being asked they're being told
our nation finds itself in the position
of a dog whose duty is not to ask why
because the why is too elevated for his
nature just simply to obey but America
is not a dog
and does not require a because I said so
jurisprudence to which it is then
commanded to catch up or legislators who
knit laws of such insulting complexity
that they are heavier than chains or a
president who acts like speaks like and
is received as a king the presidency has
run off the rails it begs a new clarity
a new discipline a new president the
president is not our teacher our tutor
our guide or ruler he does not command
us we command him we serve neither him
nor his vision it is not his job or his
prerogative to redefine custom law and
beliefs to appropriate industries to
seize the country as it were by the
shoulders so as to impose by force of
theatrical charisma his justice on 300
million others it is neither his job nor
his prerogative to shift the power of
decision away from the people to the
Acolytes of his choosing
is my characterization of unprecedented
presumption incorrect I defer to the
judgment of the people which they will
make with their own eyes and ears listen
to the exact words of the leader of
the president's transition team and
perhaps his next chief of staff who said
two years ago quote it's important that
president-elect Obama is prepared to
really take power and begin to rule day
one or more recently from the words of
the latest presidential appointment to
avoid confirmation by the Senate the new
head of the financial consumer Bureau
wrote last Friday quote President Obama
understands the importance of leveling
the playing field and creating
protections that work not just for the
wealthy or connected take power rule
leveling though it is now this has never
been and should never again be the model
of the presidency or the character of an
American president
no one can say this too strongly and no
one can say it enough until it is
remedied
we are not subjects we are citizens we
fought a war so that we don't even have
to treat kings like kings
and if I may remind you we won that war
since then the principle of royalty has
in this country been inoperative and who
is better suited or more required to
exemplify this conviction in word indeed
than the President of the United States
the powers of the presidency are
extraordinary and necessarily great and
great presidents treat them sparingly
for example it is not the president's
job to manipulate the nation's youth for
the sake of his agenda or his parties
they are a potent political force when
amassed by the social network to which
you are incessantly connected but if the
president has their true interests at
heart he will neither flatter them nor
let them adore him wherein flattery is
condescension in in adoration its
direction it's hard to say in this room
but youth is neither seasoned nor tested
enough to direct a nation nor should it
the president's business be to presume
to direct them it's difficult enough to
do right by your own kids no one can be
the father of all the nation's you is
the president therefore expected to turn
away from this and other easy advantage
yes
like Harry Truman who who went to bed
before the result on election night he
must know when to withdraw to hold back
to forgo attention publicity
and advantage no finer or more moving or
more profound understanding of the
nature of the presidency and the command
of humility placed upon it has ever been
expressed than by President Coolidge he
like Lincoln lost a child while he was
president a son of 16 Coolidge wrote the
day I became president
my son had just started working in a
tobacco field when one of his fellow
laborers said to him if my father was
president I would not be working in a
tobacco field and young mr. Coolidge
replied if my father were your father
you would
his admiration for the boy was obvious
while in the White House President
Coolidge his boy contracted blood
poisoning from an incident on the South
Lawn of the White House Coolidge wrote
these words but a father can understand
what might have happened to him under
other circumstances we do not know but
if I'd not been president and then he
continues in his suffering he was asking
me to make him well and I could not when
he went the power and glory of the
presidency went with him
sensibility such as this and not power
is the source of presidential dignity
and must be restored it depends entirely
upon character self-discipline and an
understanding of the fundamental
principles that underlie not only the
Republic but life itself it communicates
that the president feels the gravity of
his office
and is willing to sacrifice himself it
is not his eye is not upon his own
prospects but on the storm of history
through which it is his responsibility
to navigate with the specific powers
accorded to him and limitations placed
upon them not merely by man in his
design but by God in his
the modern presidency has drifted far
from the great strength and illumination
of its source the Constitution has given
life by the passionate Declaration of
Independence the Constitution terse
sober and specific does not accept by
implication address the president's
demeanor but this we can read in the
best qualities of the founding
generation which we would do well to
imitate in the Capitol rotunda our
heroic paintings one of the signing of
the Declaration of Independence
another of the victory at Saratoga
another of the victory at Yorktown and
something seldom seen in history there
is a painting of a general the leader of
an armed rebellion resigning his
commission and turning his army over to
a democratically elected government upon
hearing from Benjamin West at George
Washington having won the war and been
urged to use the army to make himself
King would instead return to his farm
George the third said if he does that he
will be the greatest man in the world he
did and he was
to aspire to such virtue and
self-restraint would in a sense be
difficult but in another sense it should
be easy difficult because it would be
demanding and ideal and easy because
it's the right thing to do and the
rewards are immediate and self-evident a
president who slights the Constitution
is like a writer who hates his horse he
will be thrown
and the nation along with him the
president solemnly swear is to preserve
protect and defend the Constitution he
does not solemnly swear to ignore
overlook supplement or reinterpreted
other than in a crisis of morality
decency or existence like the Civil War
if the president should want to hurry
along the Constitution to fit his own
notions or designs he should do so by
amendment rather than adjustment for if
he joins the powers of his office to his
own willful interpretation he steps away
from a government of laws and toward a
government of men is the Constitution a
fluctuating and inconstant document a
collection of suggestions the purpose of
which is to stimulate debate in a future
to which the founders were necessarily
blind progressives tell us that even the
flamer the framers themselves could not
reach agreement in its regard but they
did they did agree upon it and they
wrote it down and they signed it and
they lived by it its words are
unchanging and unchangeable except as
planned by careful amendment there is no
instruction to the president to override
the law and like Justice Marshall to let
it catch up to his superior conception
why is this good well it's good because
the Sun will burn out the ohio river
will flow backwards and a cow will jump
over the moon
ten thousand times before any modern
presidents conception is superior to
that of the founders of this nation
would it be such a great surprise that a
good part of the political strife of our
times is because one president after
another rather than keeping faith - it
argues with the document he is supposed
to live by this discontent will only be
calmed by returning the presidency to
the great first principles the president
should regard the Constitution and the
Declaration like an obsessed lover they
should be on his mind all the time the
prism through which the light of all
questions of governance passes though we
have sometimes gradually sometimes
radically moved away from this we can
move back to it and who better than the
President to restore this wholesome
devotion and as the president returns to
the consistent application of the
principles of the Constitution
he will also by doing so ensure fiscal
responsibility and prosperity who is
better suited with his executive and
veto powers to carry over the duty of
self-restraint to the idea of fiscal
solvency than the president of the
United States when the president
restrains government spending leaving
room for the American people to enjoy
the fruits of their labor growth is
inevitable as Senator Robert Taft wrote
Liberty has been the key to our progress
in the past and is the key to our
progress in the future if we can
preserve Liberty in all its essentials
there is no limit to the future of the
American people
now whereas at home the President must
be cautious dutiful deferential abroad
his character must change were he to ask
for a primer on how to act in relation
to other states which no holder the
office has needed to this point and
we're that primer to be written by the
American people in either 1776 or 2010
you can be confident it would contain
the following instructions you do not
bow to Kings
the President of the United States of
America boughs to no man when in foreign
lands you do not criticize your own
country
you do not argue the case against the
United States but rather the case for it
you do not apologize to the enemies of
the United States of America
and should you be confused a country a
people a region that harbors shelters
supports or cheers attacks upon our
country our enemies of the United States
and to repeat you do not apologize to
them closely related to this and perhaps
the least ambiguous of the president's
complex responsibilities it's his duty
as commander in chief of our military in
this regard there is a very simple rule
unknown to some presidents regardless of
party if and it's perhaps the biggest if
any president can face fort will follow
not just him but hundreds of thousands
or millions of others not just for the
rest of their lives but in cost of blood
and souls beyond life itself if and it's
a if that requires long and deep thought
tremendously hard labor at determining
the truth of things a lifetime of
Education the mind of a general the
wisdom of a statesman the heart of an
infantryman if after careful
determination intense stress of soul and
the deepest prayer if then you go to war
then having gone to war by God you go to
war to win
you do not cast away American lives for
those of the innocent noncombatant enemy
upon a theory of gambit or a notion and
if the politics of your own election or
your party intrude on your decision for
even an instant there are no words for
this more commonplace but hardly less
important are other expectations of the
president in this regard
he must not stint on the equipment and
the provisioning of our armed forces and
if he airs it must not be on the side of
scarcity but on the side of surplus he
must be the guardian of his troops
taking every step to avoid the loss of
even a single American life the American
soldier is as precious as the closest of
your kin because he is your kin and for
his sake the President must in effect
say to the Congress and to the people I
am commander-in-chief it is my sacred
duty to defend the United States and so
I demand that you give our soldiers
everything they need to complete the
mission and come home safe
of all the hardest choices that Congress
may have to make to achieve that and
which one of these things alone or in
combination is more terrible than the
sacrifice of our children or the defeat
of our nation if in fulfilling this Duty
the president wavers he will have
betrayed his office for this is not a
policy it is probity and it is not an
expedient artifact of my imagination it
is written on the blood-soaked ground of
Saratoga Yorktown Antietam Cold Harbor
Guadalcanal The Pointe du Hoc the Chosun
reservoir Iraq and Afghanistan and a
thousand other places in our history in
lessons repeated over and over again
the presidency a great and complex
subject upon which I've only touched has
become symbolic of overreaching there
are many truths that we've been
frightened to tale or face if we run
from them they will catch us with our
backs turned and pull us down better
that we should not flee but rather stop
and look them in the eye what might our
forebears say to us knowing what they
knew having done what they did I have no
doubt they would tell us to channel our
passions speak the truth and do what's
right slowly and with resolution to work
calmly steadily and without animus or
fear to be like a rock in the tide let
the water tumble about us and be firm
and unashamed in our love of country and
so we are
I see us like those in Philadelphia in
1776 danger all around but a fresh
chapter ready to begin uncorrupted with
great possibilities and inexplicably
perhaps miraculously the way clearing
ahead I have never doubted that
Providence can appear in history like
the Sun emerging from behind the clouds
if only as a reward for adherence to
first principles as Churchill said he
must indeed have a blind soul who cannot
see that some great purpose and design
is being worked out here below of which
we have the honor to be faithful
servants
a long time ago during the tortured
history of Rome in the fourth century AD
the Emperor Constantius son of the
Emperor Constantine was faced with an
ultimatum backed by what appeared to be
a military force impossible to resist
failure and defeat seemed certainly but
in the morning when his answer was due
he said to his assembled troops last
night after I retired to rest a shade of
the great Constantine rose before my
eyes and his well-known voice for it
bade me to despair of the Republic
we too have the voices of shades who
emerge from the past we too have what
Lincoln in his first inaugural called
the mystic chords of memory stretching
from every Patriot grave they bind us to
the great and the humble the known and
the unknown
and if I hear them clearly what they say
is that although we may have strayed we
have not strayed too far to return for
we are every one of us their descendants
the sinews are still there lively
waiting to flex we can still astound the
world with justice reason and strength I
know this is true but even if it were
not we could not in decency stand down
if only for our debt to history
the debt we owe to those who came before
who did great things who suffered more
than we suffer who gave more than we
give and pledged their lives their
fortunes and their sacred honor for us
whom they did not know for as the old
book says we drink from wells we did not
dig and are warmed by fires we did not
build and so we must remember and pay
our debt to history many generations are
gone but I see them in my mind's eye and
by the character and memory of their
existence they forbid us to despair of
the Republic I see them crossing the
prairies in the Sun and wind I see their
faces looking out from steel mills and
coal mines and immigrant ships crawling
into the harbors at dawn I see them at
war at work and at peace I see them long
departed looking into the camera with
hopeful and sad eyes I see them
embracing their children who became us
they are our family and our blood we
cannot desert them in spirit all of them
come down to all of us in a connection
that out of love cannot betray
they are silent now and forever but from
the eternal silence of every Patriot
grave there is yet an echo that says
it's not too late keep faith with us
keep faith with God and do not do not
ever despair of the Republic thank you
and God bless